so we decided to start searching for new
funding and to start working on this
bigger project that we are working on
now we found the funding from mantra
program which is a program of Dutch
Ministry of Foreign Affairs and our
partners are also from netherlands we
document on this project there are two
in universities university of twente and
deliver Erasmus University from
Rotterdam Netherlands as well as to
private companies called dance and
motorik so because of this experience
from our previous project where we
recorded audio interviews we started to
record video interviews with highlight
of the periods of Second World War
period of Yugoslavia and finally wore in
the 90s or homeland war and reporting in
Croatia methodology that's used in this
project is of course based on an oral
history principle but it also has some
some certain requests it's also combined
with some certain requests that
documented human rights organization
dealing with these issues of killing in
the past health first of all that's
giving an opportunity to people who are
not creators of historic historical
events and were not on the positions of
power and decision-making to have their
voice heard and secondly its existing on
multi-perspective of tea and sharing the
different narratives to the public when
it comes to oral history principles of
course they are focusing on life
narratives in order to establish
establish social and political context
of certain period following the
chronology of interviews experience in
order to determine which events takes
take central central role in interviews
life and of course through semi
structured questionnaire and open-ended
questions interview various people from
multiple perspectives so you heard about
the period we are recording now I will
tell you a bit more about our
interviewees and how we are recruiting
them well we had a great help from our
partner organizations NGOs from Croatia
at the local level especially the ones
that are doing the similar job and asked
dealing with the past so they in many
cases recommended to us people that are
in willing to talk and that we can
record also we searched through the
internet look documentary movies read
newspapers searching for stories about
the war where we can maybe find some
name some person that is talking about
the war some other projects that
documenta has have been also very
helpful like documenting who human
losses because it is also a field
project in which are
colleagues are going on the field across
creation conducting door-to-door
surveys with people so we used all
possible ways to get to the people that
are willing to talk because as I said
earlier it's not that often you can hear
a victim's voice in creation public and
400 or 500 interviews is a really big
amount so we didn't know what what to
expect and how many people will be
willing to talk so we recorded
interviews with people concerning these
periods of history that i mentioned
earlier and we really recorded
interviews with people from all layers
of creation society and all different
director of regions in creation our
target group target groups were of
course victims
war veterans refugees or internally
displaced persons people that were
evicted from their houses people that
were wounded during the war technical
minorities women and peace activists to
human rights activists journalists and
any interested individual who were
willing to talk and had something to say
about the war and the special emphasis
was on the people who are absent or
underrepresented in the official
narrative in Croatia which is of course
one of the main principles of world
history to shed a light on the people
from social groups that are absent or
underrepresented in earn-in dominant
narratives
so how does it work when we find the
potential interviewee the procedure is
that we mail that person more
information about the project and what
we want to do and in that letter we are
telling them that we will call them in a
week or so to to give them more
information and to give them time to
decide what they want to do with us so
after we call them of course we are
never putting pressure on people to
decide whether they want their testimony
record or not we are going to their
houses to their homes to record those
interviews because in our experience
people feel the best when they are at
home they feel the safest because these
interviews are very hard and exhausting
and of course it's really difficult to
talk about this horrible experiences
that they have
on the field from the comenta always
goes one interviewer and one camera lady
wishes are experts taluk camera things
so it is important before the interview
to do some preparations and some initial
research in order to find out a little
bit more about the person we are going
to interview and of course about the
this region or the city or town where we
are going we are trying to find as many
as information that you can present how
what's the age of the interviewee what
their ethical background do we already
know something about them regarding the
war
death territory or that time that we are
going what's the social structure of
that town what are the main historic
historical events that took place in
that town and so on regarding the
interview it usually lasts about hour
and a half but some people can talk him
longer so we never tried to stop them
and of course when the interviewer comes
to to their home to care for their
memories it is really really important
to to make a connection with this person
to act friendly and to try to relax them
and to find some fine line between
official approach and too intimate
approach before the interview starts we
are giving the interviewees written
consent for recording their memories to
sign of course if we are recording
holder people we recorded testimony from
a lady that remembers First World War
second row more than the homeland war so
many people that we are recording our
pretty also it's crucial to assist them
with
these documents because they usually
don't understand what they are signing
and it is really important for us to to
give them as much information as we can
to prevent them from feeling they did
something wrong or that we did something
wrong so they sign this i will show you
this device if you like later they sign
this consent for their for recording of
their testimony and we fill out
something that we call protocol with
them with which is basically paper in
which we are gathering basic information
on there interviewee some kind of
indicator for asking the questions
this is the consent about recording
their testimony which they sign before
the interview starts it is I translated
for you it's in creation in creation so
this document we are giving to them this
is this our so-called protocol this is
the really really good way to find out
more information about the interviewee
because in a lot of cases you don't have
any information about the person you're
going to interview so that can mean that
an interview can be pretty bad in the
end so it's better to do have some basic
information but of course if people
don't feel good about some of these
questions they are not obliged to answer
twice you to them this is just for
illustrations so you can see
and after the interview we are giving
the interviewees and two options to
choose from other two types of consent
that we have one is consent in which
they're saying that we can use this
video recorded materials printing media
audio-visual media some artistic
projects and something like that and if
they want to choose this type of consent
they can choose consent only for
research and we are with this consent we
are protecting their confidentiality and
assuring them that these
this video interview won't be used in in
public wait and of course you know
sometimes it happens that one the way
people can change their minds and we are
really respectful to that when somebody
calls and says my daughter told me why
did you do that I now scared for you
could you place in raised my interview
we do it every time and in some Cap'n's
really rarely but in some cases people
call us and asked us to be raised only
certain parts of the interview because
at the beginning especially when they
see the camera they are really scared
about talking and afterwards when they
call me they talk too much in the end so
they decide the you later date that they
said too much or the next anthem
intimate things about their relatives so
they call us the hottest to erase
certain parts which is always okay with
lots of course